manuel macro et aux mureaux dans les
yvelines le président de la république
et tient en ce moment même son discours
sur le séparatisme il a déjà fait part
de plusieurs grandes lignes de son
projet de loi qui vise principalement à
lutter contre l'islam politique est
radical
emmanuel macron prône néanmoins je cite
une meilleure compréhension de l'islam
ainsi que l'enseignement de la langue
arabe pour en savoir plus on retrouve
tout de suite sur place notre reporter
catch-up ethnique et katia bonjour alors
dites nous que faut-il retenir pour le
moment de ce discours d' emmanuel macron
sur le séparatisme alors justement
emmanuel macron a commencé en voulant
être précis dans le choix des mots il a
dit il faut s'attaquer au séparatisme
islamique un s'en vouloir
évidemment stigmatiser l'islam at il
appuyé alors il se déplacer ici en
compagnie de certains ministres dont
jean michel blanc car une annonce donc
très forte
vu qu'il y à des placements en deux
ministres il a dénoncé des erreurs des
reculs des lâchetés de la france
commises durant des décennies qui ont
permis le développement de l'islamisme
dans les failles du système
la ghettoïsation de quartier avec une
concentration
deux personnes de même origine et à ce
sujet justement concernant ce qui est
selon lui le séparatisme islamistes vous
propose de l'écouter ce à quoi nous
devons nous attaquer c'est le
séparatisme islamistes c'est un projet
conscient théorisé politico religieux
qui se concrétise par des écarts répétés
avec les valeurs de la république qui se
traduit souvent dans la constitution
d'une contre société il y a dans cet
islamisme radical puisque c'est le coeur
du sujet abordons le hainaut mon le une
volonté revendiquée afficher une
organisation méthodique pour contrevenir
aux lois de la république et créer un
ordre parallèle
érigée d'autres valeurs développer une
autre organisation de la société
alors comment se manifeste ce fameux
séparatisme islamique et bien notamment
par la déscolarisation des enfants des
prêches également des pratiques
sportives culturelles communautariser
alors quelles mesures vont être prises
ou me le demandiez tout à l'heure
justement il les a annoncés parmi ce qui
a été développée donc dissoudre des
associations problématique
et puis également stoppé leurs
subventions bien entendu fermer des
écoles illégales car certains parents
rigoriste déscolarisent les enfants et
confient les confie à ces établissements
un peu souterrains clandestins
et puis également stoppé des ingérences
étrangères en contrôlant beaucoup mieux
les financements en les taxant notamment
il ya la formation des imams a été
abordés elle sera contrôlée assumé par
le conseil français du culte musulman
une lourde tâche à dire emmanuel macron
et puis l'enseignement de la langue
arabe sera favorisée parce que c'est un
autre volet 1 2 ce qui annonce emmanuel
macron c'est à dire ne pas le nier cette
culture permettre justement aux croyants
de pouvoir être fiers de leurs origines
de leurs cultures donc favorisé par
exemple des études un universitaire sur
l'islamologie par exemple et il va il a
également insisté donc sur
l'enseignement de la langue arabe qui
sera assurée par des professeurs mais
des professeurs évidemment qu'ils
respectent les lois de la république
voici pour une série de mesures
annoncées sachant que ce projet de loi
sera présenté le 9 décembre au conseil
des ministres
katia technique en direct des mureaux
merci pour cette président précise